we're joined now by the Labour mayor of
Greater Manchester Andy Burnham thank
you very much for being on the show this
morning
well tourism is written to her
colleagues saying that history will
judge them all for the part they've
played in the brexit process so how do
you think that MPs and Westminster will
be judged by history for what they're
getting onto quite badly if things don't
change this letter actually sophie sheds
I think a bit of light on what is now
the deepest political crisis of our
lifetimes if you read it and I encourage
all people to do that it basically tells
you that it's all about the Tory Party
or should I say the to Tory parties that
we've got because there was a government
minister last week saying that the ERG
are effectively a party within a party
what she says in the letter is that she
spent the last two and a half years
trying to bring these factions together
and I think that in the end of the day
is the problem they can't be brought
together I did spend 16 years in
Parliament as you said and I sat through
all of those debates and where Bill
Clark Ash and Kenneth Clarke were just
arguing that there is no agreement
between these people and that's the
Prime Minister's failing she spent all
of her efforts to try and do that we're
actually all along there's probably a
deal that could get through Parliament
and I believe that's a deal with a
customs union as part of it as Jeremy
Corbyn has has suggested so it's a very
frustrating situation but now we are in
very perilous waters indeed you see this
is what I don't understand because it's
easy to point the finger at the finger
at the Conservative Party isn't it you
say that there is the deal to be done
with a customs union that Labour could
support but there is a customs union in
the withdrawal agreement and the future
relationship hasn't been decided yet so
why is labour risking no deal and not
backing the Prime Minister's deal I
think this is where Europe needs to
accept some of the blame because they've
set up withdrawal agreement that is very
detailed and quite punitive in some ways
but we have a political declaration
alongside it that's all very vague and
that just doesn't work as far as I'm
concerned you need to know what that
relationship is going to be if we're
going to accept all of the terms in the
withdrawal agreement but I do come back
to my main point
Sophie I don't believe the Tory party
can be united on this particular topic
at the moment it feels like the
Conservative Party is holding the whole
country to ransom and that can't be
allowed to carry on I think there is a
deal that could be put to Parliament and
the Prime Minister needs to do that
regardless of what damage it might do
internally to the Tory party without
that I don't see how we can move forward
I'm also really keen to try and pin you
down on your position on a second
referendum because I'm a little bit
confused by some of the things that
you've said about it and in the past so
in September you said as a last resort
when everything else has failed then and
only then should we consider holding a
second vote but then a month earlier in
August you said my frustration with
those leaping to a second referendum is
that it further inflamed the idea of an
arrogant political class which isn't
listening so at what point do you know
campaigners for a second referendum go
from arrogant to responsible no those
two things are entirely compatible I was
born in back in August about the dangers
of a second referendum and I still
believe that it would be fraught with
problems Sophie it would cause lasting
division in the country I think for a
generation
so those comments stand when I then gave
a more detailed speech in September I
said it should be the very last resort
the only thing that I think is worse is
a No Deal brexit so in that scenario
when we are at that Cliff edge at that
point I would support a second
referendum and I think actually that was
broadly the position that was then
adopted by the Labour Party at its
annual conference so I remain in that
position today I do believe we should do
everything possible to honor the result
of the referendum and get on with a deal
a brexit deal that works for us the
customs union is crucial Greater
Manchester sends 60% of its exports to
Europe you know we cannot be in a
position where from the beginning of
April onwards those businesses are
facing barriers and tariffs we can't
because that will damage those
businesses it will result in jobs being
lost so that is why we're saying we need
that working customs arrangement and I'm
afraid the time has
for the Prime Minister to part company
with those hardliners in her party
because there is not a deal that she can
do with them that will be acceptable to
the rest of the country so just to be
clear if you're saying that the only
thing that's preferable to a second
referendum is No Deal
does that mean that you'd accept the
Prime Minister's deal above a second
referendum no I don't think we should be
forced to accept a suboptimal deal you
know with all of the uncertainties
around the situation in Northern Ireland
that no I don't think we should be
required to accept that there is a
better deal I believe that can be done
and one that could unite Parliament and
it's a deal that has a customs
arrangement as part of it I think there
is a majority in parliament for that but
the Prime Minister won't put that
proposal to Parliament for fear of the
damage it will do internally to the
conservative and unionist party now this
is the problem Sophie this is the point
that we've arrived at you know all the
Tory leaders in the past have taken on
these hardliners and I'm afraid it's
time for the Prime Minister to either do
that or let Parliament take control of
this situation okay and we talked a lot
about and conservative divisions over
brexit and which are pretty clear there
are also labor genuinely held labor
divisions over brexit as well there's
also a lot of rumors going around about
a new party forming about some MPs
perhaps splitting away from labor and
resigning the whip do you think it's
inevitable that that's going to happen
no I don't think it's inevitable the
colleagues that I worked with in
Parliament have a deep loyalty to the
Labour Party so I think at the moment
it's more speculation than than reality
but you're right it's a very turbulent
time in British politics Sophie and
we're living through a degree of
uncertainty I don't think any of us have
ever experienced and that there has to
be a realignment I guess coming out of
all of this you know in these parts I
think the big thing that people felt
when they vote in the referendum wasn't
just that they wanted a different
relationship with Europe they wanted the
UK Parliament to work differently to
look after parts of the country like
this there have always been neglected in
our London centric system so I think
coming out of this we do need to see
some Realignment not necessarily within
the political parties but actually
within the country I don't think we can
carry on with this over centralized
political system as I say that's very
London centric and leaves large parts of
the country without the investment that
it needs and that is so obvious when you
come to transport or pier and the
difference between transport here and
what people experience in the south so
you know these are the kind of issues I
think that are going to need to be
addressed when we finally come through
this brexit debate and we must come
through it so because we experienced a
real blight here on day to day decision
making we're still waiting in Greater
Manchester for the government to give us
the compensation for the cost of the
mall and fires back in the summer I mean
this isn't the normal running of UK
government you know things are
completely on hold at the moment and we
can't carry on like this because we're
drifting into very dangerous territory
indeed if you are and you know I mean if
things are as bad as you paint a picture
of them
why isn't labour doing better in the
polls is it the leadership that's a
problem I think we're in a position here
where as you say there's there's no
unity if you like in the two main
parties so I think the country are
saying through those polls that they're
not sure where both of the main parties
are you know there's a poll today that
says they're neck-and-neck I think that
reflects that fact that there's a
confused debate going on in the Tory
Party and a confused debate going on
within the labour party that's what the
opinion polls are saying right now I
think we do need to come through this
period and get back to focusing on
domestic issues that have been very
neglected I would say in the last in the
last two years people are living through
really tough times but there's not a
sense at the moment that people in
Parliament are understanding that or
doing anything about it I think the
level of disconnect Sophie between
Parliament and the people has never been
greater than it is right now okay well
let's talk about some of those domestic
issues shall we and homelessness is
clearly a huge issue for many towns and
cities across the country and you said
that you would eradicate homelessness in
Greater Manchester by 2020 you've only
got a year to go are you going to do it
I didn't quite say that I said I would
end rough sleeping and there's a
difference between those two things but
I'm not trying to do the politician
thing and sidestep well we recently
recorded the first fall in levels of
people sleeping roughing Greater munch
there for eight years so we believe
we've turned the tide and things are now
heading in the right direction and one
of the reasons for that is because we
are the only city region in the country
that through this winter has sought to
give a place for every person sleeping
rough to go every night of the week and
it's had really impressive results it's
not a perfect scheme but already almost
500 people have moved from that stable
provision within those shelters to a
fixed address and this is my frustration
Sophie to be honest if the government
were to focus a little more on
bread-and-butter issues like that I
think we could make more progress more
quickly instead we saw a universal
credit rolled out here over the course
of the last year and that only added to
the problem that I'm facing but but
nevertheless no I don't back away from
it in my view in this day and age in a
country as wealthy as this we should be
able to put a roof over every head every
night of the week and I don't believe
that perhaps some people who are
successful in society other people have
to sleep in doorways this in my view is
a national scandal we have the means to
fix it we should get on and fix it you
know the need for safe affordable
housing in my view should be a human
right in UK law and I believe those are
the some of the changes we need to see
to bring this country back together once
this brexit debate is over and just
finally what we've got you and Donald
Trump who's called today on the UK and
other European and countries to take
back Islamic state fighters or else and
put them on trial otherwise in his words
they're going to permeate Europe now
there are dozens of jihadis from
Manchester who are currently unaccounted
for
so what do you think should happen do
they need to come back to the UK and
also how do you deal with jihadi wives
such as shamina Begum
well you won't be surprised here that
not for the first time I don't agree
with Donald Trump nah I don't think it
should be automatically people come back
I I read all the details of that story
last last week and if somebody leaves
this country and joins a group that is
actively plotting to to harm and kill
people in this country it surely can't
be right that then people come and walk
straight back in when it's convenient
and yeah I know that some of those
caught up in the Manchester attack feel
very strongly about this situation
because of the echos with the situation
that happened there so no I don't
believe that Donald Trump is right about
this I understand the legal complexities
that the government will be facing but I
would think the vast majority of people
here in Greater Manchester's country and
if you've walked away and joined a group
plotting to harm us that you don't come
back and the thing was with this the
lack of remorse that was what I think I
found really shocking and I'm sure other
people would find shocking too so it's a
difficult situation but no I don't
there's any guarantees that that is what
happens okay and do you buy them thanks
very much for being on the program